okay don't you play the next James Bond
someone actually called James Bond which
superpower would help you do your job
better I don't know but I'd quite like
to be able to fly just a little bit
above the ground not totally it was just
a little bit about the ground that week
why not how did you get an agent who
well I did lots of lots of comedy and
then I went and asked a dramatic agent
if they'd be my agent even though I have
lots of comedy which is bizarre way of
getting a good agent and she is good
which part do you wish you'd had the
chance to play or direct I don't work
that way I just like the ones I've got
it's it's all cool what three things you
need to do your job determination
determination determination what's the
most devious thing you've ever done to
get a part in the film food to get on
the phone I haven't anything devious but
I did go along on velvet goldmine to
audition for one part like I said I
don't want an additional four that I'll
audition for another pearl and Todd had
said yes you know I think with the
internet now and with how easy it is to
come across a good camera that that
there's really no excuse to not just
make a movie on your own and also just
being very accepting of everyone
really because actors can be quite weird
and you know they all have their sort of
tics and ways and it's you know it's
such a privilege to see how odd everyone
is but at the same time it can really
affect your day